We've been following all of the different
possible paths forward for treating the virus.
We've talked about antiviral of antivirals.
We've talked about antibody treatments.
We've talked about the path to a vaccine every
time that this comes up.
I am careful to say these are things that
are being considered in early testing.
We need to know more.
We don't have much data yet.
I now have for you today, and there is a degree
to which we we are sort of on the on the vanguard
here of of the treatment of this.
We now have promising results from not one,
but two of these studies.
And we're also learning a lot more about possible
predispositions to getting a more serious
case of the virus.
We'll talk about that as well based on blood
type, some early data about that.
So let's jump right in.
First of all, is Avogadro's OK?
I told you about AV again earlier this week,
AV against the Japanese antiviral.
It was developed by a subsidiary of Fujifilm.
If you can believe that back in 2014.
The idea was the Japanese government wanted
to have something to stockpile against a serious
flu epidemic at some point in the future.
They said this is as good a time as any to
test it on coronavirus.
And for a while there was mere speculation
that AV again may be effective.
We now have a clinical trial involving 340
Chinese patients and the results are that
AV again is turning people negative for the
virus after a median of just four days compared
with a median of eleven days for people who
did not get the drug.
We've heard it can take weeks for the body
to fight this naturally median seems to be
11 days.
That means half take less than eleven days
have take more than eleven days.
AV again reduces the median to four days.
Lungs X-rays of the lungs improved within
four days.
In ninety one percent of the people taking
AB again, compared with just 62 percent sort
of fighting the virus naturally without assistance,
so to speak.
The results also say the safety of the drug
in terms of side effects seems high.
That's been a concern with Afghan.
Still need more information there.
So that's all the good news.
The thing to keep in mind about the Afghan
trials so far is that they seem to really
only work well for people with mild to moderate
cases.
If you have a case where it's more serious
and the virus is already well established,
the Afghan does not seem to work particularly
well.
So this could possibly be approved as a coronavirus
treatment by May.
And that's very interesting.
Second, and this is even more exciting in
my mind.
I told you about the French biologist and
medical doctor.
In other words, he's an M.D. and a biology
p._h._d DDA Rao, and he's been doing some
very good small trials.
He has now published very good results from
a trial about chloroquine.
I mentioned chloroquine as a possible treatment.
Chloroquine is a really old cheap anti-malaria
drug.
It's been around since 1934.
It's very inexpensive and it has shown some
some promise in treating the virus.
Dr. Rao found in a small trial that a 600
milligram per day dose of hydroxy chloroquine,
which is a version of the drug, reduced the
viral load in swab tests significantly.
That's great by itself.
But now it's getting even more interesting.
Dr. Ruth did an additional test combining
the hydroxy chloroquine dose with a zero Meissen.
Now, if a Cythera Myson sounds familiar to
you, that's an antibiotic widely available,
sold under the sort of marketing name of Zithromax.
I took it years ago for a sinus infection.
It's very commonly taken for a number of different
bacterial infections.
Combining a zip throw Meissen with chloroquine
in Dr. Rao's studies seems to be even better
now.
I know what you're going to say.
Well done, David.
This is a virus, not a bacteria.
Antibiotics work on bacteria.
Why on earth would a zero myson help a zit
throw?
Myson, despite being an antibiotic, has been
shown in a number of peer reviewed studies.
Google it.
They're widely available to have antiviral
effects specifically on bronchial cells in
COPD patients, COPD, of course, a respiratory
illness.
So there's something about a 0 myson that
has a mechanism.
That works specifically in the lungs.
This is very interesting.
And again, all of this warrants more study.
But the chloroquine treatment modalities are
being tested in more and more places.
There are calls now that Seattle doctors should
start testing this protocol.
They have a large cluster of cases.
It would provide for some good data, but it
could also maybe help a lot of the patients
in that Seattle cluster.
So all very interesting.
Lastly, we're now learning about possible
sort of genetic or underlying markers that
might make people more or less susceptible
to the disease, it appears.
This is again, this is early blood type might
be a factor.
There is a non peer reviewed study from Chinese
researchers on twenty one hundred patients,
large sample size.
And the idea that they've found is that if
you have blood type A, you might be at higher
risk for Cauvin 19 compared to all other blood
types.
And blood type O has lower risk for Kovil
19.
It's not all or nothing.
It's a spectrum.
It's not been peer reviewed.
But this is the type of thing that we're looking
at.
The next question is, if you confirmed the
blood type stuff.
Would it allow us to modify or tailor treatment
on the basis of blood type in some efficacious
way?
This is all hypothetical at this point.
So there's very bad news every day about the
number of cases and the real spread of the
infection.
We're also getting good news every day and
we're learning something new, getting a little
bit closer.
We just need to keep staying away from each
other while doctors, medicine and science
do their work.
Let me know what you think about this latest
news.
I'm on Twitter at De Packman.
The show
is
on Twitter at David pac-10